and I've got to start watching the
Kardashian show this was one of the most
serious and nuanced discussions of the
issue of surrogacy that I've seen
anywhere on television and it came from
Khloe Kardashian I felt really guilty
that like this woman just had my baby
and you're just I take the baby and then
I go to another room and you're sort of
separated like I felt it's such a
transactional experience
because it's not about him
[Music]
I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy
and the difference of it but it doesn't
mean it's bad or good it's still great
okay and then there it is right at the
end that's the required endorsement of
the sexual Revolution and all this
Progressive insanity